رسائل بوتين الغامضة. طاولة
عملاقة وقهوة بحذاء روسي. شاهد
كيف تعامل بوتين مع رؤساء
العالم. صاحب القبضة الحديدية.
رجل الظل الطويل الذي جعل من
بلاده دولة يهابها الجميع. الرجل
الذي شارك والده في الحرب
العالمية الثانية دفاعا عنها
ثاني اطول زعماء الكرملين بقاء
في السلطة. انه فلاديمير بوتين
الرئيس الروسي الذي اثبت حضوره
القوي اينما ذهب صاحب النظرة
الثاقبة التي يمكن ان ترى بها
القوة والغضب تارة والود
والعاطفة تارة اخرى. بين احراج
اعدائه والترحيب باصدقائه. يخرج
لاحدهم بكلب ويستهزئ باخر.
ويستخدم ايحاءات للجميع وبمقابلة
مع زعيم اوروبي او امريكي يترك
رسالة يستغربها الجميع من حيث
الشكل والاسلوب لدرجة يعتبرها
اعلام اهانات مباشرة. شاهدوا كيف
يتعامل بوتين مع رؤساء العالم.
يعلم جيدا انها تكره الكلاب.
لذلك في عام الفين وسبعة وبينما
كانت المستشارة الالمانية انجيلا
ميركل تتحدث مع بوتين على هامش
اعمال مؤتمر سوتشي فاجأها كلب
بوتين الاسود المعروف بكوني الذي
اخذ يتمسح على ساقيها ويشمها
الامر الذي تسبب في توتر كبير
مستشارة الالمانية التي تعاني من
رهاب الكلاب منذ ان عضها كلب.
وفي عام الفين وعشرين استقبل
بوتين الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوجان بعد اسبوع من مقتل اربعة
وثلاثين جنديا تركيا في قصف جوي
بادلب شمال غرب سوريا وقد استشاط
اردوغان حينها غضبا خاصة ان
الرئيس الروسي ابقاه منتظرا قبل
ان يظهر ويطلب منه الجلوس تحت
ساعة ذهبية. وضع فوق تمثال
برونزي للامبراطورة كاثرين
الثانية المعروفة بغزو شبه جزيرة
القرم وانتزاعها على اثر معركة
مع الامبراطورية العثمانية في
عام الف وسبعمائة وثلاثة
وثمانين. وحين كان بارك اوباما
رئيسا للولايات المتحدة كمنافس
قوي لواشنطن وكان يصدم اوباما
بالنظرة الحادة حتى جاء موعد
لقائهما في روسيا. ودعا اوباما
فطور روسي تقليدي وسقاه قهوة
محمصة بالحذاء السوفيتي. رشقة
بعيون خضراء تتقن الترجمة
الفورية مرتدية بدلة جلدية قصيرة
وفي سن السادسة والثلاثين من
عمرها انها الروسية داريا بوير
سكايا. التي تولت الترجمة
الفورية للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين في اللقاء الذي جمعه
بالرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب
والوفد المرافق في قمة مجموعة
العشرين في اوساكا باليابان عام
الفين وتسعة عشر مشهد جعل
مستشارة الشؤون الروسية بالادارة
الامريكية تعتقد ان القصد منه هو
اغراء ترامب والهاؤه والمعروف
عنها بحبه للنساء. ويبدو بان
بوتين نجح هذه المرة ايضا حيث ان
ترامب بدا سعيدا للغاية خلال
حديثه وجها لوجه مع بوتين قائلا
حسنا ساكون قد معك لبضع دقائق
لكن هذا فقط امام الكاميرات. ثم
سيغادرون وسنتحدث بعد ذلك. وهو
ما فهمه بوتين جيدا وكان محل
تقدير منه. الرئيس الفرنسي
الاسبق نيكولا ساركوزي. لن يكن
استثناء من تعامل بوتين الفظ.
فقد مر هو الاخر بلحظة غير سارة
اثناء لقائه الاول مع بوتين عام
الفين وسبعة الذي ظهر بعده لاهتا
ونظرته غامضة وصوته مبحوح. وهو
ما ارجعه احد المتابعين الى
استخدام بوتين شتائم بعد عدة
ملاحظات ادلى بها ساركوزي حول
وضع حقوق الانسان في روسيا
وغزوها للشيشان حينها قال بوتين
لساركوزي ان بلدك بهذا الحجم
الصغير. وبلدي بهذا الحجم
الكبير. والان انت امام حلين اما
ان تتابع بهذه النبرة وعندها
ساسحقك واما ان تغير اسلوبك
وعندها بامكانه جعلك ملكا على كل
اوروبا ليخرج بعدها ساركوزي
مغادرا الجلسة وهو يترنح هنا
وهناك وتظهر عليه علامات نقلت
خلفها خوفا كبيرا. ولم يتخلى
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين عن
هوايته في اهانة رؤساء فرنسا حتى
في احدى اسوأ الازمات التي
تعرفها اوروبا والتي تهدد جديا
باندلاع نيران اول مواجهة مباشرة
بين الولايات المتحدة الامريكية
والناتو من جهة وروسيا من جهة
اخرى. اذ لم يتوانى ساكن
الكرملين عن خرق عدة بروتوكولات
عند استقباله نظيره الرئيس
ايمانويل ماكرون الذي اتى سعيا
لبحث سبل تخفيف التوتر. وقد
استقبل الرئيس الفرنسي امام
عدسات الكاميرات دون الاقتراب
منه. وظل بعيدا عن نظيره لامتار
اكثر مما تتطلبه الاجراءات
الاحترازية المتعلقة كورونا رغم
ان هذا الاخير ظل يرتدي الكمامة
وطلب بوتين من ماكرون الجلوس في
اقصى طرف طاولة بيضاء طويلة
بينما جلس هو في الطرف المقابل
اذ اعترض على جلوس مترجم بقربه
وطلب منه استعمال السماعة الخاصة
بالترجمة الفوري. ليوصل رسالة من
استقباله هذا فسرها المتابعون ان
المطروح من جانب الاوروبيين وما
تريده موسكو بعيد جدا وان طلب
بوتين اخراج المترجمين خلال
لقائه بماكرون تم تفسيره على انه
يرفض الوسطاء ويريد فرض لهجة
بلاده في الشأن الاوكراني على
الرئيس الفرنسي. لكن هذا المشهد
لم يكن الا الجزء الاول من مسلسل
الاهانات. اذ ان ما حدث بعد
المؤتمر الصحفي كان اكثر اثارة
للانتباه فبعد اللقاء الذي تم
بين الطرفين لم يكلف بوتين نفسه
على انتظار ماكرون للخروج معا من
القاعة كما ذلك البروتوكول بل
امام عدسات الكاميرات تركه خلفه
وغادر بينما كان الثاني لا يزال
مشغولا بجمع ملفاته وقد بدت عليه
علامات الاحراج. من كل هذه
اللقاءات يتضح بان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يحترف تكتيكا
خاصا يصدره كشخصية كارسيماتيكية
مسيطرة على كل الضيوف ويوصل من
حيث الشكل في لقاءاته مع كل
الضيوف رسائل مباشرة اعمق بكثير
مما يدور فعلا من نقاشات. هذه
المشاهد تختلف كليا عندما يلتقي
بوتين بزعماء يحمل لهم الحب
والولاء. فالاستقبال يكون مختلفا
والطاولة الكبيرة تصبح صغيرة.
والايدي تتصافح والاجساد تتعانق.